is this song is this alright here we go
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday yes October ah what's today the
28th 29th the 30th it's gonna be the
30th this is my first live one ever I'm
sitting on at the very best at very
metrosexual couch this looks like a lot
of guys blue other guys on this thing
this is this is sort of the reverse W
Hotel the way they have this thing like
the W Hotel it just looks like
everything's been just on and that a
bunch of Yolo douches had a threesome
there or something this looks like is
there like a gay chain of hotels that
just caters to gay people you know see
this is why this is gonna be weird with
the live crowd because to me that was no
big deal everybody got real quiet
they're like it's like that was a
problem is he trashing gay people is he
saying that there should be segregated
hotels no I am NOT okay I'm just saying
that it would be nice if you could
separate them from the general
population in the hotels okay that's
what I'm running on I'm gonna out hate
Trump and [ __ ] into me whenever the next
stupid election is gonna be I'm gonna
out hate them I'm just gonna start
calling them a [ __ ] and I'm just gonna
[ __ ] I'm gonna hate even more than
him then I'm gonna get elected and then
I'll tear down whatever part of the wall
he made which I know is a hot-button
issue here in Arizona oh yeah they
should have the wall oh they shouldn't
that's what I out run on a platform I
would run on a platform that gay people
should have their own hotels
I'm so sick of walking into lobbies
seeing men holding hands with other men
and just started off on something
bizarre like that just so I can watch my
opponent go wait a minute I never even
thought about hating this
you know why won't Hillary Clinton go
away why can't she just understand that
nobody likes her she just [ __ ]
hanging around just like that [ __ ]
kid who just shows up that nobody tell
her there's a party and then she shows
up you know you know what happened with
her and no one ever poured blood on her
and a [ __ ] prom that's what they
should have done to finally [ __ ] get
rid of her you know she just keeps
hanging around like she's a winner you
know did Jim Kelly hang around after
losing four [ __ ] Super Bowls he
didn't he [ __ ] disappeared and every
once in a while an NFL crew finds the
[ __ ] guy and it goes hey Jim let's
talk about your career yeah and I don't
wanna I really I really don't want to I
did have a great career but all you want
to dwell on is the negative oh my god
she says she's just admit she tries me
know she's gonna [ __ ] she's gonna
take volume you still can't hear it what
louder what alright this was the dumbest
for you guys listening at home who can
hear this totally fine there's like 500
people staring at me right now bitching
that they can't hear it so I'm holding a
microphone with a yellow windscreen and
a little [ __ ] lapel mic alright as
far as I can tell only the foreigners
for some reason can't [ __ ] hear me
everybody has some sort of Australian
tax now that see out [ __ ] people
foreigners coming in look the [ __ ] did
you come here for - tell us how [ __ ]
up our country is I love when people
come here and they can they start
bitching about this country it's just
like then I don't do that when I go to
Australia talk about how [ __ ] up your
country is that only around the edges is
it livable
it's [ __ ] unbelievable if you can't
see the ocean you just completely you're
in no-man's land
no-man's land 200 the most poisonous
[ __ ] snakes ever do I say that when I
go to Australia no I don't I just go
look at the surf oh my god it's gorgeous
absolutely beautiful look at that sad
tan guy blowing into that giant horn I
bet he used to own this view way back in
the day but his ancestors didn't what is
that what is the call on that you know
what I mean
I never understand that when I was in
[ __ ] Canada the rule was what did
they say like I called them the the
natives the natives of Canada and they
got all [ __ ] offended they said we're
called the originals the original
everything with Canada the original six
the original people you know what I mean
the original recipe and whatever [ __ ]
syrup they're trying to sell you you
know what I mean each other everybody
loves Canada like they're a bunch of
friendly people they're not they're all
a bunch of [ __ ] racist sticky people
they're in a bad mood from yanking that
sap out of the [ __ ] trees and then
what do they do they kick all the
indigenous people all the way up north
you know to give them a perimeter
between them and the polar bears that's
what happened you know you ever see any
of these big Hollywood types talking
about them Meryl Streep you know I don't
know I picked her I'm still pissed at
her that she said the martial arts are
not the arts oh really what would you
know about that oh I get it you wear a
wig and you pretend to be other people
like by all means let me listen to you
about social issues you get your [ __ ]
goddamn car to go back to your gated
community when does she ever see
minorities huh when she looks into the
front seat of whoever's driving
by all means Merrill tell me tell me
what society is like from behind your
gated community somebody told me today
that it's it's there's legislation right
now going through I don't know where
does it go through the government right
now I'm thinking to school house rock
songs right now I'm just a bill
yes I'm only uphill and then it's off to
the white house where there's something
something and then it comes back to a
bunch of white men and they vote to see
if it will be alone um how I hope and
pray normally I wouldn't sing in public
but I feel like I'm in my bedroom I have
plush furniture like this in my bedroom
look at that one with the [ __ ]
overhang sorry did this go out again
with the sorry sorry I'm sorry to each
and every one of you especially the
Millennials I'm sure you're [ __ ]
heard about it and you're gonna hash tag
some sort of me too me too
I couldn't hear either me too me too I
also had something bad happen hey here's
something you can say in this country
three [ __ ] meals a day me too me too
first world country me too flat-screen
TV me too everybody dwelling on the
negative
he's [ __ ] feminists man I swear to
God I want to go to one of their events
and just get up to that microphone and
just be like excuse me is there anything
good about being a woman at any point
during your day are you like thank God
I'm a woman or I would have had to step
in that muddy that mud puddle whatever
the [ __ ] I'm supposed to do supposed to
take my [ __ ] coat off you know a
little more respect for these feminists
when they care a little bit more about
guys jackets you know it's always a
[ __ ] issue that they care about you
know and in the 70s we were forced to
wear clogs and a lot of our mothers blew
out their ACLs gives a
[ __ ] I'll listen to a feminist but not
if she's white you know what I mean it's
like you know I won't okay at the end of
the day you were a white woman in the
United States of America what is the
problem huh did someone take away your
rose' for the afternoon
did they shut down the [ __ ] trolley
down at the mall what what is happening
in your world
no seriously all right look if you live
in some honey booboo lifestyle right
you're living off the Appalachian
somebody got rickets and Lyme disease
right husband never wear a shirt you
know what I mean he just wears that long
underwear with the trap drawer behind
the back you know what I mean you know
he's going out when he puts on his best
overalls right
those guys have it right those guys know
how to live up there if you truly want
to get along with the woman you got to
live on right off the Appalachian Trail
you know you got to be off the grid and
you just have to have no television okay
and then you can slap her around all you
want and she's never good enough this is
just how it is
you know what I mean if you have a dirt
floor like taking a beating is not the
Bigham just seems like part of your life
it's like seemless worst thing you could
we ever did for women is linoleum and
like wall-to-wall carpet then we lost
all of our power yeah you've seen it
when Twitter first came out women were
just hash tagging whatever you say and
now somebody's gonna take a snippet of
that and put it on a [ __ ] news show
and then I'm gonna get in trouble are
you trying to say that women deserve to
be beaten on dirt floors and at that
point you just got to go with it just be
like yes and I'm running for president
in [ __ ] 2020
and don't even get me started with the
gays in the hotels that's right you run
the most hateful [ __ ] campaign ever
you don't wear the Confederate flag but
all of your suits if you look quickly
have all the colors of it alright and
then in the end you just totally flipped
the whole thing you flip the whole thing
you have an openly gay guy as a [ __ ]
like sitcom level gay you know what I
mean not like real gay like TV gay
you don't mean TV gay it's kind of like
when you watch wrestling how they
enhance their personalities that's what
they do with with gay people on TV they
gotta just go [ __ ] through the roof
with the sass you know what I mean
rather than just having it coming out
surprisingly every once in a while I
don't know what I'm talking about it
feels like what does this feel like come
along if I'm a doing up you owe 10
minutes and 48 seconds there you go this
is my world this is my life this is what
I do this couch is not this couch just
feels like it was made out of old coats
like a couple of old tarps or some [ __ ]
like that I hate how it's trying to be
plush this was considered like right
here this was considered fancy in the
70s if I could just get this lapel mic
up here this is just any time there was
a button that was sunk all the way in it
to try to make this look plush you know
even though it feels like [ __ ] week
old bread that you laying on honey all I
want is the cat this is what I literally
have to do I have to [ __ ] put the mic
down here
it just won't clip on in any [ __ ]
area that is acceptable now the people
at home can't hear well because I
clipped it on to them this is like the
biggest lapel ever everything a bumble
bee thought it's supposed to be like
barely noticeable isn't it alright you
know what I don't give a [ __ ] let's
let's read about some let's look up some
Phoenix news here Phoenix news ladies
and gentlemen let's see what's going on
and greater Phoenix you know what this
shows are minding me up do you guys
remember when cheers went off the air
and Jay Leno tried to do it live and the
whole cast got shit-faced you remember
that and he had nobody to talk to when
he [ __ ] it we'll do it live all right
let's look up Phoenix news all right
what do we got here all right update
woman critically injured in west Phoenix
shooting has died let's see a woman shot
killed in Phoenix early Saturday morning
standard that's standard okay
homeless man beat CBS worker for sun
block that's a new one
suspect is designed is described as
looking like if che guevara [ __ ] a
lizard Phoenix police arrest suspect in
deadly shooting what is going on out
here
stolen truck from Phoenix captured on
speeding why don't they have anything
nice Phoenix wedding invitation
designers must serve LGBT Oh Arizona
here we go they don't like Mark and Luke
Martin Luther King they don't like the
gay law all ga.js oh the goddamn gays
what are they gonna do they're gonna
walk around and enjoy themselves get
back in the house where God wants you
phoenix woman 21 accused of abusing
three-year-old boy see ladies it goes
both ways women also beat men let's read
that one this is always uplifting huh I
don't know why this there it is all
right there we go okay Phoenix woman 21
accused of abusing a three-year-old boy
all right my first question is a juror
be like well what did the kid do
you know I mean can the kid walk is it
big enough to make a fist you know what
I mean
there's no excuse to hit a woman so if
this kid was punching on her you know
because it wanted to breastfeed or some
[ __ ]
then I think she had every right to just
pick him up by his OshKosh B'gosh is or
whatever push him right off that plastic
pony a Phoenix woman who's been who has
who had been reported missing earlier
this month along with a three year old
boy now faces child abuse charges in a
case court document says I'm not going
to say her name but I swear to God her
first name looks like tequila 21 was
arrested Thursday on suspicion of one
count of child abuse in connection with
injuries to the toddler
I'll shake it off investigation said in
a court dog I'm supposed to far into the
beating of a child I can go just how
quiet this crowds going to get the child
was beaten on its birthday because it
wasn't happy with the cake the suspect
said well if he didn't like the cake
you're surely not gonna like this lit
candle all right I'm not reading the
rest of this I'm not reading the rest of
this this is too sad I don't know what
is wrong I take this back this is fun
making you guys [ __ ] really
uncomfortable I'm enjoying the [ __ ] out
of this let's read some more sad news in
Phoenix let's see how far down we can
buy the weight you can feel the downtown
air it's about ready to blow up Ike I'm
telling you got a great food area down
the street you got a you got an arena
is a CVS come on man that you can feel
it I sense this in Cleveland and it
turned around I knew it was gonna happen
in Detroit and who's kidding who Phoenix
is the Detroit of the southwest it is
you just never had a riot cuz you don't
let african-americans in your state
that's what yes that's what it is who
sue says no to a day off you guys ought
to be ashamed of yourselves
all right what else okay local headlines
this is ended with this here I don't
want to [ __ ] on you guys too much all
right
Valley traffic closures that's not
exciting thank you for backing that up
man no it isn't I did not pay money to
come out listen you took do the traffic
report I can listen that on my AM radio
thank you very much County offers free
dog adoptions to ease the crowding all
right let's talk okay we already got a
[ __ ] beat up kid let's talk about
abused animals is my dog we're in there
no my dog lives in a house out here that
I bought for it so go [ __ ] yourself
what was happening is is the amount of
money that I was spending to board the
dog was less than a mortgage out here so
I said [ __ ] and I set up like a Hugh
Hefner lease with my trainer it's like
alright as long as the dogs alive you
live here rent-free and you take care of
it and I come out and visit whenever I
want he's like cool I go when the dog
dies then you know you either buy the
house so you can leave you start renting
he was like cool so you know damn well
that dogs getting [ __ ] sirloin every
night it's Cleo the dog's name is Cleo
and she barely remembers me now because
she's getting treated so well [ __ ]
house is nicer than my one in LA so
there you go mr. guilt trip over there
now let's talk about let's talk about
this [ __ ] over here let's talk about
what you guys do two dogs in this state
what is with this [ __ ] advertising am
i on Netflix what happened coca-cola we
are so much more than Cola yeah your
[ __ ] gum disease where's Nia
she's right backstage she'll be out in a
minute I'm [ __ ] with you she's at
home taking care of our child uh-huh
uh-huh not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen sir just like your
dreams that is not going to happen your
dreams won't come true and Nia's not
coming out here if anybody watching that
Texas Tech Oklahoma game Jesus it was
like no [ __ ] defense in that man none
whatsoever
by the way thank you to everybody here
thank you thank you to everybody here
that is Dennis come out to the all
things comedy podcast network our first
ever podcast festival it's been a
smashing success did you guys see when
you walked in we had them we had
Caddyshack playing outside you can play
that a cornhole [ __ ] game you can
drink a bunch of beers this is what's
all about it's all about hanging out
getting [ __ ] up listening to morons
who don't know how to read do podcasts
that's what this entire thing is all
about all right what do you guys alright
Houston what about those [ __ ] Houston
Astros going up two to one two to one
against the LA Dodgers I don't know who
to root for in this one cuz you know I
live in Los Angeles you know I know
Houston just had that hurricane but it's
over right everything dried up those
fans look all happy and dry when you
watch the game me almost almost to the
point I was just going look how nice
this looks what was all the [ __ ]
complaining about Jesus Christ it rains
a little bit and everybody out in
Houston starts losing their [ __ ]
minds
you know do you think one of them has
ever sent a postcard to Seattle those
poor people sit and rain for like 360
days out of the [ __ ] year I will
guarantee you not a [ __ ] peep not a
peep from Houston
Houston Jesus what a shady city that is
huh NASA how many people down there do
you think I bet that whole [ __ ]
Houston that whole [ __ ] hurricane I
bet it didn't even happen I bet they
just let some damn water go down there
and it was all an excuse to kill the
last few people alive that that were
part of the the fake lunar landing
reenactment at NASA so they got rid of
them and what else goes on in Houston
they got the Klan right outside there
that drags people to death which I'm
suppliers didn't get an applause break
here in [ __ ] Arizona it was one other
thing what the [ __ ] was I talking about
I was talking about now and then they
got Halliburton Halliburton that changed
their [ __ ] name I know I know I know
we're over there to [ __ ] what are we
doing over there where we're concerned
about their freedom we've got to get
these Iraqis to be free
no when it gets awkwardly silent here oh
you know what I did Oh
so anyways I think I'm gonna be I think
I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you right now
why the [ __ ] Astros are gonna win the
World Series okay I'm gonna tell you why
it's gonna happen it has nothing to do
with baseball it has to do the fact that
Jason lawhead is rooting for the Dodgers
he's here tonight
Jason lawhead grew up in Cleveland
alright he's [ __ ] okay like the second
you come out of the womb the curse of
that city just engulfed him and
everywhere he goes he's like the mush
and a Bronx Tale just tear up your
[ __ ] tickets la it's over you're not
gonna win another game um you know I
have no idea I'm actually rooting that
there's gonna be there's got to be seven
games I hope it'll be seven games give
me something to do I don't know that
there's gonna be seven games do you know
that there's gonna be seven games sir
does somebody know all because of the
money yeah I thinks it's all about the
money that's why I don't give that's why
I don't give to charities anymore I'm
done with [ __ ] charities I didn't
give one [ __ ] dime to Houston okay
you want to walk up to me
would up to your neck and water with I
live in Houston hat then I'm gonna give
you money all right but I'm not giving
to any of these [ __ ] things anymore
because that these [ __ ] organizations
they keep I'm convinced that the most of
them they just they just keep the
[ __ ] money that's what any time you
see a tragedy just know that there's a
bunch of people going I can make a bunch
of [ __ ] money off of that hashtag I
care too right and then you give them
$20 you feel like you did your part you
know what I mean like how much money
think Trump collected before he went
over there with those Bounty paper
towels it just handed him out in Puerto
Rico he must have made a [ __ ] killing
probably spent the rest on hair plugs
and [ __ ] I don't understand how he
became a redhead as he got older I don't
understand he had brown hair it's like
somebody transitioning like I don't get
somebody like changes religions not all
this is gonna make sense everybody you
can't still can't [ __ ] hear me I
don't know what to do should I stick
this in my [ __ ] mouth then could you
hear me all right how's that is that
good does this work is this working for
both of you maybe if I clip this onto
onto the microphone Jesus Christ you
know what this feels like right now this
feels like when I was in summer school
and I was just staring at the [ __ ]
clock like 23 minutes 23 minutes Jesus
Christ why did I wear a sweatshirt out
here oh by the way I got to do a I got
to do a promotion I got to do a
promotion I saw I went to a movie
premiere of the 34:30
the Nature Boy Ric Flair is coming out
I have to tell you this right now might
be the best 3430 I ever [ __ ] saw it
should be not it actually it is ninety
minutes
it is ninety minutes I thought it was
only thirty minutes oh it was ninety
minutes sir it wasn't your dream came
true see that everybody I'm gonna start
a charity for this guy in a portion of
the proceeds are gonna go to towards him
the rest of him are gonna go to me and a
new [ __ ] drum kit I'll put his
picture on the bass drum head each day
thousands of people are dying of cancer
and I want a boat if you call this
number we can put a slight dent in it
and I can get the boat of my [ __ ]
dreams and finally get rid of my wife
and start living openly with my mistress
please take the number down the first
300 people that call in will get a free
t-shirt with a donation of over three
times the cost to produce this t-shirt
no one will check to see if the t-shirts
were actually sent out that's the move
people there's two [ __ ] there's three
moves to make in this country at this
point if you want to exist in the future
one you either grow weed an anticipation
that it becomes legal at a federal level
and you can get it out of your [ __ ]
state because I know in Colorado that I
guess they're drowning in the [ __ ] they
got more weed than they got hippies they
got more oh my god I gotta tell you that
the dirtiest look and white people
you're ever gonna see in your life are
in Colorado I can't imagine being a
minority in Colorado looking at the
white people there you got to be
thinking like how the [ __ ] are we
working for these people how are these
people running [ __ ] I mean everybody
just looks like they fell into a vat of
patchouli right
you know I always inner tubing and [ __ ]
they just live outside that just I don't
know that's like in the Denver area you
know then you get out in the western
part of the states and then then then it
gets better you know you got the
Illuminati's in the Rocky Mountains you
know what I mean they make sure it stays
nice and cold up there so the body of
their first wife never it never melts
away you know what I mean that's what
they keep doing that's the code word
what you going skiing with your third
wife today yeah but going on the double
black diamond that's code for I'm gonna
[ __ ] steer her into a tree you know
that's what's gonna happen when global
warming really hits and all the snow
melts up and [ __ ] Aspen and Vail the
amount of dead women that are gonna be
underneath there the amount of First
Wives the before I made my first wil
million love you know what I mean when I
was at the college level before I went
pro you know I don't know sometimes I
think you ought to be able to kill your
first wife though because there's like
too many people on the planet and then
also can maybe like put them on their
heels not saying you do it but just the
fact that she would know it was okay I
think from where I sit would have a
really positive effect on the
relationship I think the reality
television viewing would go down I
should do these more because with you
guys laughing I won't get in trouble you
know what I mean it's when I'm by myself
and there's dead silence it stops
sounding like I'm [ __ ] around and it
sounds more like is this guy reading
from his own manifesto
yeah they ought to come up with creative
ways to get rid of people I guess the
optimal number according to something
that somebody sent me is 500 million
people on this planet and we're up to
6.5 billion so I think that there's
there's things that you could do like
stop rescuing pit bulls you should just
set them free and let them wander the
streets in packs and then everybody has
a cyanide pill you know so if you get
you know if he wants to be ripped apart
by a pack of wild dogs you can just eat
it every once in a while oh maybe you do
that like I don't know like there's some
sort of incentive for your family if you
offer yourself you know what I mean and
I figure if you offer yourself that's an
even better way because then they can
like prepare rather than just have a
bunch of carcasses on the side of the
road that will cause diseases which is
good but after a certain point you be
once we get under 500 million now you
just killing the chosen wants the blue
chips right they should have like an NFL
Combine to find you know you got to get
your like every country has to get their
roster down to it down to a number right
like you're allowed to have a hundred
thousand people you're not allowed to
judge it by race religion sex or
anything like that right and you just
have the best of the best of race sex
religion all of that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
we care about right you just have that
cruise ships now no cruise ships that's
not gonna work cuz that's also an
environmental disaster I regret doing
that bit on my last special I never
thought of all the oil that was going to
be seeping there so my new one is that
you just let him pull into port and then
you just you just Mull mall down
they die happy there's silly hats and
their flip-flops I know no no that's
right this is at a time like this don't
you think this should be more caring
somebody told me today that they're
actually selling land on Mars can I
somehow get in on that can i I'll sell
you the whole [ __ ] planet for 15
grand you can get out there and figure
out there's no atmosphere then you're
gonna die it's a shame I mean it's there
you can see it look right through the
telescope I sold you that if you can get
there and breathe it's gonna be all
yours it's gonna be all yours
that's the way you know something right
there that'd be the first way of how you
get rid of people you sell land on Mars
and anybody that goes to buy it you go
okay you want you got a little bit of
land come down here to claim it and then
they walk into a room like Joe Pesci in
Goodfellas all right you put a gun to
the head you like hey wait a minute what
the [ __ ] it's like well dude you
obviously don't want to be here you'd
rather go to Mars it's too crowded you
know I'm gonna send you to heaven man
you can see all the planets all right I
like what people wonder if there's if
there's life on other planets you know
what I mean like why would you you know
who gives a [ __ ] if there is you can't
talk to them they're too far away
you know and what if they're smart
enough to get here do you really want to
wave your arms you know why don't you
just hitchhike down the [ __ ] highway
and see what happens all right I gotta
do some Reed's here for this week okay
here we go oh look who's Oh endo Chino
in dope
endo cheeto talked about how every man
looks better in his soup
you know when I'm having gay thoughts
you know if I was gonna [ __ ] a man I
would I would prefer that he was in a
suit because I don't want to feel dirty
afterwards I'd like to feel that I was
with the gentleman that was raised right
you know last thing I'd want to do is
[ __ ] a gay guy from Denver wearing his
flip-flops and his [ __ ] Hawaiian
shirt it's probably the last read for
these guys right Indo Chino is making it
easy to get a perfectly tailored suit at
an incredible price you can choose from
hundreds of top quality fabrics and
personalize your suit just the way you
want it whether whether it's for work or
a wedding or another spell others spent
another special occasion I can't read
people endo Chino has suited up hundreds
of thousands of men and are now the
largest maid to [ __ ] measure
menswear brand in the world place your
order and wait for it to arrive just in
a few weeks don't go to work sit there
creepily staring at your front door like
that crazy asian chick in that [ __ ] up
movie where she stares at the phone
before she pukes in a bowl and makes the
guy eat it you ever see that one yeah
it's called the audition check that one
out but not before you get a great suit
now bill burr listeners and whoever the
[ __ ] else they advertise with I love
other ways try to act like it's
exclusive like they haven't horde
themself out to anybody who with a
microphone King it's probably some
homeless guy outside reading the exact
same [ __ ] copy in a [ __ ] empty
refrigerator box listeners can get Indo
Cheetos best deal ever at three and $59
for any premium suit when you enter the
code bird during checkout that's 50% off
the regular price for a maid to imagine
a [ __ ] suit premium suit plus
shipping is free that's in
Chino calm promo code bird any premium
suit for just three hundred fifty nine
dollars and shipping is all incredible
deals it is felt like a rock star there
I let you guys hit the high notes right
like one of those hair metal guys who
can't [ __ ] hit the high notes in it
he just [ __ ] sits in nodding at you
with that devil look it's an incredible
deal for a suit that will fit you better
than anything off the rack ever could
alright oh look who's here everybody
I'll look the next one it's all zip
recruiter are you hiring
do you do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidate zip
recruiter is different that's why zip
[Applause]
accrued up with zip recruiter you can
post your job to over 100 [ __ ] 100 up
I just cursed to give myself time to
catch up 100 of the web's leading I feel
like I have like like a strawberry in my
hand that I'm just never gonna eat with
this little lapel like somebody's saying
something really interesting you don't
say really little [ __ ] acorn with zip
recruiter you can post your job to over
100 of the world's leading job boards
with just one click so you can rest easy
knowing your job is being seen by the
right candidates then zip recruiter puts
it smart matching technology to work
actively notifying qualified candidates
about your job within minutes of posting
so you receive the best possible med
matches find out today why zip has been
used by growing businesses of all sizes
and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates with immediate
results and right now my listeners can
post job on zip recruiter for free for
free that zip recruit accom / / one more
time don't save recruit until I point at
you one more time try it for free go to
zip you [ __ ] blew it the key is you
got to make them feel like the [ __ ]
the recording staff take to come on
Phoenix you're better than this one more
time to try it for free for free go to
zip comp slash / alright we got through
it
oh and here's the last one here's
another great one oh it's me undies
everybody
do biondi's me on DS as always one con
who doesn't do it right
doo-doo-doo-doo p on DS biondi's i hope
someone kills you tonight all you had to
do was listen to me i don't have two
mics i should have three i don't know
this [ __ ] windscreens is soft as your
taint when you wear a pair of this
[ __ ] [ __ ] they make them for the
ladies drying out your [ __ ] clam all
right sorry okay me undies everybody me
undies makes your button what me undies
your butt will be proud to wear I hate
that [ __ ] word it's either your ass
you know but it's just too you know I'm
an ass man I just that word never just
but that's if you have a flat ass you
have a bunt dude over lower back down to
your ankles you know what I mean that's
how I'm built naked I have the exact
same silhouette as the Pink Panther big
head big feet just [ __ ] straight
right down and swear to god you could
hang advertising off my backside all
right me undies makes undies your butt
will be proud to wear and check this out
I'm not the only one who loves me undies
listen to my longtime listener and me
undies enthusiast George has to say is
this George Michael did he write this
from beyond the grave
maybe he was the first monk me undies
remember that when he was shaking his
ass I think it would be nice if I could
touch your body and [ __ ] jerk you off
in a [ __ ] port-a-potty
then get rested with cheese in my
stubble wearing my [ __ ] cowboy boots
I like that guy and now he's dead
alright a note from George n/a Bill burr
listener and me undies fan I decided to
try out me undies because I love beep
bill burns me undies jingle I smile
every time he sings that this reeks of
being rewritten by the advertising
what kind of man says that I just look
out the window and smile do you do you
just smile when you I don't believe a
word of this although it's so easy to
skip ads in a podcast I always listen to
bills reads and I'm so glad me and he
says stuck what did Al Gore write this
it's this is about as sincere as him if
I told you guys my theory on why Hillary
keeps [ __ ] losing even though she
only lost once it's because she has Mike
Dukakis is charisma and she's isn't
comfortable in her own skin is Al Gore
and you combine those two and what you
have is a dope that loses to an even
bigger don't oh man this is a trump
state I can feel it oh yeah is he making
it better for you oh it's too late it's
you had a chance you had a chance of the
day off and you said no this is the
[ __ ] candidate you've always been
waiting for huh just coming and wearing
his red tie this [ __ ] silk underwear
telling you how it is alright although
it's so easy to see who gives a [ __ ]
about this [ __ ] guy smiling looking
out the window with silky balls before
me undies I used to buy a 3-pack of
underwear at retail stores until I
realized that I wanted to treat my junk
to something more comfortable and it's
and that starts with a great pair of me
undies cradling the family jewels to get
20% off the best and softest underwear
and socks you will ever own for free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
go to me honey stop calm / bird that's
me on DS dot-com / / alright I started
to hype something here 40 minutes
everybody just like that just like that
40 min
that you'll never get back I thought he
was going to be standing up I thought
there was going to be more of a show I
thought there'd be showgirls I saw I
might as well stand up it's so [ __ ]
hot in here all he's standing up he's
he's standing up he wants the world to
know that the [ __ ] podcast huh what
do you mean speak up I got to [ __ ]
microphones here how much more can I
speak up sir
are they cancelling each other out with
amplification are they both polite no
you go no you go we were both born in
the 90s I don't want to offend you with
my yellow skin and your black skin I
[Applause]
want to sit in this big chair because I
feel like I would think that I know
something over here here we are ladies
and gentlemen welcome to another episode
of masterpiece podcasting wow this is
weird now I got in here there's a whole
new sound in here I hate that I'm at the
[ __ ] old age where I have to cross my
legs when I sit down I don't know what
happens remembers a kid you just [ __ ]
sat down I gotta sit there constantly
stretching out my [ __ ] hip this couch
was supposed to be nailed down so I saw
the premiere of the Ric Flair Nature Boy
dote I don't think I've ever [ __ ]
laughed that hard I mean I have to go
back to like a Richard Pryor special
that guy is arguably one of the funniest
[ __ ] human beings ever and I have to
tell you something what I can commend
about that guy in this Nature Boy 34:30
that you have to [ __ ] see is he did
not run from anything he owned up to
everything good or [ __ ] bad
they were sitting there talking about
like you know him [ __ ] around on his
wife and he was just going yet you go
how long were you faithful for in your
marriage he just goes one day
and he was like I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it I came home and I spent a
day with my family and I was like bored
out of my mind
I was in hell and it was so [ __ ]
refreshing to hear a married guy talk
about how badly he wants to continue
[ __ ] as many women as he possibly
could right now I know the laughs are
gonna go down because there's too many
women here and every guy has to sit
there and act like he was you know like
probably thinking about it right [ __ ]
now I don't know but I yeah he talked
about everything just being like just
all the women he was with and at one
point they cut back to his first wife
who he calls number one now this guy is
a [ __ ] legend and she does cuts back
to him and she's just like yeah Rick
wasn't a family man I was doubled over
laughing and then you know it definitely
has its sad points but he doesn't run
from it you can say he's a bad father or
if he's maybe like an alcoholic yeah I
don't want to ruin too many of the lines
but he was just saying like I don't know
if I'm an alcoholic I never tried to
quit
it was just one [ __ ] closing bit
after another with this guy it's like I
would close with that I would close with
that I would close with that and he just
kept going he did tell this one story
I'm all twisted up in my twenty [ __ ]
microphones he did tell this one story
to the crowd that was there he talked
about how we one night he was on the
road and he was out partying and he goes
and I woke up with a couple of girls I
woke up next to an alien which is what
he calls being like blackout drunk and
and just waking up next to some woman
you don't even know her [ __ ] name so
he goes I woke up and there was an alien
alien on one side in an alien on the
other and I looked down and my Rolex was
missing so I wake the women up and I go
hey where's my where's my watch and they
go you don't remember they go you don't
remember and he goes no he goes yeah
last night you threw your watch into a
bowl of spaghetti and you said I got 15
of these [ __ ] things this was just a
throwaway story I mean it's a comedy
club this is a packed house I'm killing
just remembering lines that he said I'm
telling you have to [ __ ] watch this
guy is it's like I'm telling you they
ought to give him like the Mark Twain
award they're always giving it to like
these these [ __ ] people you know I'm
you know they give it to some people
that are funny but then other times they
just you know sometimes that's like that
guy is not as funny his [ __ ] Ric
Flair you got to get him in there you
know you know they wouldn't know cuz
it's always like the you know the arts
and Meryl Streep and but blah blah blah
the [ __ ] out of here you know do you
think she could [ __ ] be that good an
actress after a couple of back body
drops you know
you think she could do the flare flop
and keep that keep that period-correct
wig that she has on I don't know why I'm
trashing Meryl Streep I have no idea
what you know why because she's always
getting Awards you know yeah [ __ ] her
for doing such great work [ __ ]
you know this business works if you
trash anybody you inevitably you end up
working for them I can't tell you how
many times that's I haven't gotten a lot
of acting work but every time I've ever
gotten acting work and I'm in the
[ __ ] hair and makeup I always get to
skip the hair part of course I go over
to the makeup side of the trailer
inevitably somebody comes walking in I'm
like oh [ __ ] I trash that person I hope
they didn't hear that podcast alright I
think that was it you guys want to
listen to some reads here for this week
can you hear me is everything fine is
this is this working how has this been
so far if you guys enjoyed this this is
something I should do more of all right
I've already loved one guy there's
always gonna be one guy booing I didn't
like it alright on Monday I discussed
silkworms and how they take the spittle
from a silkworm and that's how they make
a silk shirt somebody goes silkworms hey
you ugly red-faced [ __ ] [ __ ] you
really think silk shirts are made from
silkworms
really jesus [ __ ] christ dude just
think about it just think about that for
a second bless your heart bill but sweet
[ __ ] man get your act together and go
[ __ ] yourself you know what's funny is I
did and I still do until I was thinking
like wait well how would they turn that
spittle into thread but I also used to
think that a [ __ ] I used to think a
pony was just a little horse I did and I
remember these people down the street
they had they had up they had a little
pony and I just remembered I just
remember thinking why won't when is that
thing gonna [ __ ] grow up and become a
horse and I finally one day asked my
mother when I was like 15 and she just
looked at me like
how did you come out of me what do I
Google here what is silk made out of
it's just gonna say silk but what they
shouldn't call it a [ __ ] silkworm
then what is silk maida what is silk a
[ __ ] you sir this [ __ ] I know that you
don't know okay oho everybody likes to
feel so goddamn smart huh
what is silk made of this right here if
there's ever a Hunger Games I'm
definitely not going to make it right
here the protein fiber of silk is
comprised mainly of fibrin and is
produced by certain insect larvae to
form cocoons all right I was kind of
right the best-known silk is obtained
from the cocoons of the larvae of the
mulberry silk worm wait a minute was I
right what the [ __ ] well it wasn't
spitting it out I thought it was
basically a silkworm spider web why
would a worm make a spider web bill that
may be suicidal I don't know there's
another way to make money off of
suicidal sink silkworms each year over
30,000 silkworms commit suicide and I
would like to buy a Tesla so please send
your money in all right fat but fit
Billy no rolls a study just came out
that speaks to everything you've said
about being fat almost automatically
meaning you're not healthy today there
are a lot of people who say you can be
in good health while carrying fat but
that's just to soften the blow to people
who can't lose the lard alright anyways
thought I'd share you're not as dumb as
Nia says you are
but maybe still a bit of a [ __ ] just
kidding go [ __ ] yourself I had no idea
how much you guys laugh at these people
[ __ ] on me I thought I thought you
were all sitting at home as offended as
I was going hey don't say that about
bill bill it's my podcast friend well
well well well I guess you get to see
your [ __ ] friends are when you do
something live all right I don't even
this is how shoot bad my short-term
memories I don't even know what the [ __ ]
I just said I didn't want to just read
that you could be a fat [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah no yeah you know you don't want to
be fat like that's a big thing now to be
fat and be proud of it you know and they
talk about fat shaming and all that [ __ ]
it's just like you know you should just
ignore what everybody says and you
should listen to your heart
going for the love of God lose the
weight I'm gonna conk out here ah that
was a cheap joke that was an easy one
I set you up you know easy I took you to
the left and then I went right that's
what I did it was the old misdirection
you know comedy crossover there all
right
Nestle [ __ ] Nestle [ __ ] that's Rio
yeah they're the ones they're the ones
causing all the wars hey there Billy in
the mirror I saw this article about
Nestle that I thought might ruffle your
feathers the line the byline says it all
okay this year this year's Halloween
confectionery oh this is so great I have
people here what the what is of
confectionery it's a white it's a candy
store what kind of an [ __ ] calls it a
confectionery
you know what's funny I got this acting
gig right now
by the way I got to promote the movie
you got to see it next you probably come
out next year it's called front runner
front runner stars Hugh Jackman is Gary
Hart if you're old enough you remember
Gary Hart yeah Gary Hart we went a
little Ric Flair on the road all right
he bangs some woman and then all of a
sudden he couldn't be president anymore
and that's how that's how Bush got in
because this guy was a good-looking guy
and all the ladies liked him and that's
all you need to do to win the presidency
right you play the saxophone you hit a
jump shot you know what I mean you do
something like that and then everybody
[ __ ] loves you anyways that's coming
out by the way all you hear on a movie
set is people go and copy that
copy that copy that I need this go over
there copy that and I get it when you
say it into like a [ __ ] you know
you're on a little your little CB radio
copy that I get that you don't I mean
but people say it to just other people
now just one person will be a can you
move that over there and a guy go copy
that it's like why don't you just say
okay it's a lot quicker can you move
that okay got it
copy that those are the same kind of
people that call a [ __ ] candy store a
confectionery
all right yeah hey that's that's called
a callback the guy just goes copy that
he was waiting for the end of the bit
see that now how does he know about
callbacks how does he know cuz Netflix
has released 30,000 stand-up specials
this year they're creating a comedy
special housing bubble over there come
watch the greatest open my kurz do an
hour of their best material that's who
they're down to at this point there's
like everybody has an hour special I'm
gonna freeze myself after I die don't
they to have that here the cryogenics
right next to the confectionary right
I'm gonna freeze myself so and then when
they figure out how to cure death they
can unfreeze me and I can do a bit of I
can do an hour-long one-man show on
Netflix about what it's like to be in a
40 year coma
all right net nestle everybody by the
way f is for family please watch that on
Netflix now that I've made fun of them
just scroll if you can't find it just
scroll left for like 20 minutes
[Laughter]
anyways this year's Halloween
confectionery will contain palm oil
grown on land that should lawfully be
habitat be a habit I can't read this h
ABI ta t lawfully be habitat to
orangutans I was supposed to rang a tank
like the drink
orangutan s' rhinos and clouded leopards
I don't know what the [ __ ] that is
despite commitment to clean up supply
chains this is on top of them siphoning
that this is this you know a lot of
times it's not me this is the sentence
this is on top of them siphoning my
[ __ ] screen just went out finally
gonna make a point this is on top of
them siphoning they do of water from
national parks that you've spoken about
I guess they take water out of national
parks where they had agreements with
Native American tribes that have since
expired what's it going to take to end
Nestle's corruption maybe you can take
this up as your cause the way the first
lady's do this is how you stop that what
you'd have to do is have politicians
politicians have to start earning
fuck-you money rather than being grossly
underpaid the fact that you know as a
podcaster comedian and actor you can
make almost as much if not more money
than the President of the United States
is [ __ ] pathetic you don't to me they
should have [ __ ] you money the second
you become president they should just be
like I'm like you know like a pitching
machine that's just throwing one [ __ ]
heater over the plate should be a bag of
money the entire time me there so then
when these guys go hey can we siphon
this [ __ ] out of here you can be like
now [ __ ] you well if you don't we won't
help you get reelected I don't give a
[ __ ] I got [ __ ] you money
it probably wouldn't work I know
sometimes I have good ideas sometimes I
don't
so I guess yet don't buy any Nestle
Crunch Bars everybody and stay away from
their bottled water and whatever else
they make did they make thongs alright
do you feel how the podcast just
immediately [ __ ] slowed down the
second I started reading out loud it's
[ __ ] unbelievable why do I do this
why do I do this to myself what is this
shame it's because I was raised Catholic
alright accidentally made two girls my
girlfriend all right I like this guy
already hi William the bald big fan from
Kenya oh this is a second language
alright love the podcast and f is for
family is amazing that's amazing that
you can watch it over there no you
should see go on f go on the internet
you can actually watch all these people
you know you know what f is for family I
feel like captures the Frank character
that's loosely based on my dad you know
which one I think does it the best is
Mexico you know because they got a lot
of [ __ ] the same kind of people
screaming and yelling temper you know
what I mean it just [ __ ] works great
somehow that'll come off as racist but
it was supposed to be a compliment long
story short I have had a crush on two
ladies in my college class for over four
years Jesus Christ this guy moves slow
huh now one of them is dying of ovarian
cancer and I feel like it's too low geez
is not that we care we care in Phoenix
huh I bet you guys all pictured a white
vagina
yeah [ __ ] act like you guys care how
you try to bully me into your [ __ ]
phony giving his [ __ ] they probably
showed that hurricane and [ __ ]
Houston on Comedy Central out here
that's how little you people care guys
are all about yourselves
[Laughter]
alright all I did alright I don't know
where I am and it's I don't how you
follow a white vagina next item up for
bids a white vagina mica - mica Moxon's
for serial killers it would just be like
woman's body parts oh we're so offended
oh [ __ ] all of you I'll steer even
harder into it did you hear that they're
gonna start having Jeffrey Dahmer Day in
Wisconsin that's - they have an
all-you-can-eat miss and all-you-can-eat
mystery meat day in Wisconsin they're
trying to change the perception that all
they do is eat cheese up there see are
we done groaning cuz I'll keep [ __ ]
going alright so this guy's had a crush
on these ladies for four [ __ ] years
but since breaking up with my previous
girlfriend three years ago I decided to
not get into another relationship so the
whole time you with this girl for three
years you had a crush on two other women
for four years I love this guy he's a
[ __ ] mess all I did with these two
girls was like flirting from time to
time what is like flirting in Kenya what
I was gonna do some starving joke
you want a piece of bread just [ __ ]
with you are you gonna have it he's
gonna write back next week next week
dear bill we are not Somalia or Ethiopia
we actually have food in Kenya running
water and skyscrapers anyways all I did
was flirt with the one that one of them
is the fun friendly kind but she's kind
of loose parentheses open relationship
and sending nudes types alright so
that's the one you bang you [ __ ] you
double wrap it right you double wrap it
and the other is conservative the other
is conservative introvert virgin but I
really do enjoy her company all right
there's the one you have kids with this
is an easy one well a few days ago it
was my birthday and I had both of them
and you had both of them you're just
gonna stop there you banged both of them
us she's not a virgin anymore now is she
I had both of them and some few friends
over if this is his second language and
I can't read for a party I had a
shitload of booze and was on I'm gonna
guess right now the one that he thinks
is loose with Helder alcohol and the
virgin blue everyone at the party that's
what I'm going with
maybe I've been in Hollywood too long
but this can't be linear it has to make
a left turn at some point to spin us
into the second act
okay well a few days ago it was my
birthday and I okay and both over Iran
right blah blah blah blah blah they came
over I had a shitload of booze and was
on autopilot the whole time but
apparently I had the balls to ask the
two ladies to be my girlfriend all he
was drunk I don't believe this is a true
story or did he watch some Kenyan
version of The Brady Bunch
when Peter has two dates in one night uh
a few days later I got a text from both
of them asking whether I was serious
about asking them out I'm now in a huge
dilemma of choosing between the two who
I really like and the fact that I
haven't been in a relationship in a
while and basically forgot how to be in
a relationship oh shut the [ __ ] up you
remember exactly how to be in a
relationship that's why you don't want
to be in one
any advice would be appreciated and okay
and uh Yujin Dean yeah which is Swahili
for go [ __ ] yourself
all right well I think I think you got
to go with the [ __ ] you know if you
don't want to be in a relationship but
you did say girlfriend I would just own
up to it just be just be like listen
I've been I was totally shit-faced when
I sent that but I have had a crush on
you for four years you always got to go
with honesty with women guys go into it
you know you always think you got to lie
to him and all of that [ __ ] you gotta
just you just [ __ ] lay your cards on
the table it's the best thing you can do
they won't get mad they might get a
little upset depending on what you say
you know depends on how graphic you get
where do you see this going I see you uh
laying off the edge of my bed on your
back with your head hanging off as I
[ __ ] your mouth while watching
SportsCenter
that might be a little too honest you
could just say you know just looking to
have a good time I would just go with
honesty I would tell both of them dude
you see the fact that you're not in a
relationship right now you get to hit
the reset button you just go total
honestly I would tell them exactly what
the [ __ ] happened just say I had crushed
on both you for [ __ ] for I would have
talked to him both the same time but I
would say I sent it to two different
people and that's what I did and then
just wait to hear what they say that's
it and if they don't like it who gives a
[ __ ]
take you and your honesty to the next
situation I'm telling you all right
that's the best way to handle the
[ __ ] thing and then I don't know
somehow you just tell them what's going
on out Christ I gotta tell the store
here's a story for you one time
what I learned about honesty I was in my
[ __ ] early to mid-30s I was just sick
of lying and I met this chick she was
like 22 years old so we get back to my
apartment this lady's leaving right now
she can't bear to listen to this right
now so we get back to my apartment we
start making out and everything and she
goes wait a minute she goes like wait a
second she says where is this going
and I said nowhere are you kidding me I
go I'm like 50 years old and then you by
the time you thirty I'm gonna be like 86
years old all right this is gonna go
nowhere so whatever you want to do
sexually but you don't want to do with
somebody that you like you do with me
right and then you'll never have a
midlife crisis because you got it out of
your system and you know what she said
she went all right that was it
yeah they're not as prudish as you think
they are don't be a fur that's the
number one thing you gotta you gotta go
with the [ __ ] honesty do you like me
no no you don't have to be mean you
don't have to be me I like you but not
like that all right girlfriend loves my
long hair I don't oh go [ __ ] yourself
Jesus Christ what do you do next go up
to somebody with leukemia my girlfriend
loves my sick free body but I don't I
just love how you guys have this thing
with disease what is it with you guys in
disease why does it make you so sad it's
Mother Nature trying to help us they
should close down all the pharmacies
okay and if you're lucky enough to be
disease-free you live that's what we
need to do tough decisions have to be
made okay so I've been growing my hair
out for a while since I enrolled in
college oh dude that's the time to do it
good for you grow your hair out
Livius steven seagal years in your 20s
get by a sword sit there Indian style
meditating out on the [ __ ] some sort
of bluff or what I never went to college
really I never lived there what do they
call it out on the compound the the quad
area at the grassy area just try to act
interesting anyways and I'm about to
graduate this upcoming spring my
girlfriend and a few friends convinced
me to grow my hair out since they are
all the hippie type oh that's not the
cool long hair this guy probably goes
the University of Denver
I don't consider myself a hippie at all
but that is the crew I run with since I
have known most of them since back in
high school and they are all close
friends a couple of them have long hair
- I was open to the idea since I've had
short hair for most of my life before
that the long hair turned out looking
pretty good too my girlfriend though
loves the long hair on guys
a few days ago I told her passingly that
I've been thinking about cutting it and
she immediately seemed really concerned
saying I just don't think it would look
good and but I really love how it is and
she just dating you for your hair sir
but that she's only ever dated guys with
longer hair dude if you're looking to
get out of this relationship one quick
trip to the [ __ ] barber this is the
easiest breakup ever and you got to go
hardcore I get like a cop flattop
haircut
the detective mustache this is the
easiest breakup ever her concern kind of
annoys me as she was saying that she
would not be attracted to me in general
if I if I cut it to me it seemed pretty
shallow considering we've been together
for almost three years yeah dude she
doesn't love you she doesn't love you
get your [ __ ] haircut and get out of
there that's what I do I'm pretty fed up
with my long hair and everything that
comes with it knots hair tryin you know
getting it in my eyes cut yeah dude you
yeah you learned something you know you
did something for her not for [ __ ]
you right you don't like it you're
telling you you don't like it she says
she doesn't like the fact that you don't
like it it's all there sir all right
this is what you do you [ __ ] one more
time and then you go get your hair cut
I don't advise you doing that that's
mean I just I just needed a laugh okay
here's the last one everybody and then
we'll Loma we'll be almost at the end of
the podcast hour and 10 minutes just
like that first ever live one there you
go all right guys lie on tinder surprise
hey old bill I'm a 29 year old single
lady living in Virginia along with most
other singles my age it seems I've had
to try out various dating sites and apps
over the years but haven't had any
success cultivating anything more than a
date here or there I realized this alone
my god this is so [ __ ] long lady
maybe if you got to the point you'd get
a second date that was a cheap shot
admittedly that was a cheap shot
I got anxiety and how long this was and
rather than admitting to the fact that I
don't like to read out loud I blamed her
I'm sorry and I'm sorry for your
horrible social life let's continue I
realize a lot of this was likely due to
the fact that I've been pretty
overweight my entire adult life now now
I'm sad however the last year and a half
I've managed to lose 112 pounds au
that's [ __ ] awesome it took you a year
and a half good for you 112 pounds and
Counting she's not done yet she's like
John Elway she's getting the rings at
the end of her career and to take in all
that [ __ ] in the press she's finally
living up to her expectations I love it
and counting and counting by changing my
diet and literally running my tits off
on the elliptical for an hour five times
a week that's [ __ ] amazing good for
you and anyways last week on tinder I
matched with a very cute 29 year old guy
he initiated the conversation we had a
great back-and-forth comparing what
podcasts we listened to I found out he
actually lives in Ohio and was
only traveling in my area for work for
the next few days all right that's a red
flag and he's on tinder he's all gonna
get his dick sucked all right that's it
he doesn't want to know how many
brothers and sisters you have and what's
your hobby Oh do you like to cook
fantastic why don't you cook my balls in
your mouth as I stroke my dick over here
brutal honesty women like honesty
anyways I know I should have called it
quits then but finding out someone that
had that can actually hold the
conversation seems to be a real rarity
these days he asked me out to dinner but
because of my diet and wanting to be
nice I offered for him to come over for
a home-cooked healthy meal when you
didn't fill him into the back story now
he thinks he thinks he's getting anal
this is how guys think okay we want this
whole me to thing to end guys have to be
honest about how they think all right he
came over was just a cute was just as
cute in person as in his pictures the
great conversation kept flowing I can't
believe he just met somebody on the
internet and invited them over to your
[ __ ] house please tell me you had a
[ __ ] pistol taped to the inside of
your leg the great conversation kept
flowing in six hours later we were
making out we both had to be up early
the next day he left with plans to hang
out again the next day after work we did
and ended up hooking up he left Virginia
the next day but we continued to message
pretty constantly over the next week
with him initiating the conversation
most of the time I swear to god there's
three paragraphs left and I want to
apologize to each and every one of you I
want to have a benefit for all of your
ears having to listen to me have to
[ __ ] read this goddamn lawn please
call the number at the bottom of the
screen and a portion of the proceeds
will go to everybody's eardrums in this
room and also my dodge two-door Hemi
pickup truck
for 40 grand
anyways all seem to be going pretty
great except the eight hour distance in
between one another well yeah okay you
guys never looked at a globe however you
know what there's an I in Virginia
there's an I in Ohio they must be pretty
close don't they alphabetize by a vowel
in the middle of them or something all
seem to be going pretty good okay except
for the a blah blah blah blah blah
nothing really came okay however I just
had a feeling something wasn't quite
right so I googled him
I'm guarantee he has a family nothing
really came up except his I don't know
what profile then a few lines down I see
an old wedding gift registry site with
his name I called it I swear to god I
didn't read this before you think this
sounds bad out loud you should hear when
I read quietly and I just hear me
stuttering in my brain I searched all
the girls names on the registry along
with his last name on Facebook and bingo
all over this girl's profile are cute
pictures of a sweet couple the other
half of which is the guy that was in I
was in bed with a week ago the son of a
[ __ ] is married what do I do here bill
do I call the guy out on his [ __ ] and
rip him a new one
do I send his wife a message and tell
her what he's doing he travels them all
the women are going yes all the guys
like no no no move on move on he travels
the majority of the time for work and
I'm sure I'm not the first person he's
done this to he already deleted his
tinder profile and our text message have
only been PG for the most part so I
don't have any concern concrete proof to
send her I feel completely wretched
wretched
wre TCH IDI wretched all right I was
right Jesus Christ wretched I thought
this one you like pukin retching how all
right everybody's got a degree in the
room I feel completely wretched and
terrible for the most part I unknowingly
played in this entire I played into this
entire situation no you didn't you
didn't unknowingly if this is like one
of the oldest [ __ ] stories on the
Internet
also any dating advice for me moving
forward is also appreciated thanks for
the advice and congrats on that
beautiful baby girl of yours oh thank
you very much all right
Hey Oh Billy became a father all right
first of all I got to be honest with you
you're kind of going Hillary Clinton on
this thing where you're not taking any
responsibility for this loss whatsoever
you're blaming him you're calling him a
piece of [ __ ] you're of the electoral
college you're blaming the sand and
eastern rebels everything but you okay
you went on tinder tinder is a total
hook-up site it's full of [ __ ]
scumbags like and then guess what you
met a [ __ ] scumbag so what I would
take out of that is to not go on dating
sites and I would try I don't know I
would join like a [ __ ] sports league
or some [ __ ] like he'll play some
softball I would try to do some hobby
thing I know this sounds like an old guy
thing but like you know the [ __ ]
Internet is the Internet now if you want
to go blow up this guy's life to make
you feel better I mean you you can also
do that I mean I mean I don't know what
I do I just when I [ __ ] up I just go I
[ __ ] up and I just I walk away from it
I mean if you want to if you want to do
that that's up to you I don't [ __ ]
know I mean who knows maybe maybe his
wife isn't blowing him you know let's
try to blame his innocent wife now
you know I just feel like in this age of
hyper feminism the way women always just
stick up for other women that guys need
to start doing this so I have to stick
up for this complete piece of [ __ ] here
[Applause]
maybe maybe you know maybe just this the
loves gone in the relationship they got
the kids he doesn't want to leave he
just wants to know what it likes to have
fun again and you were fun and he
[ __ ] you know it's kind of on you
though because the first night when you
just hung out all you got to do is look
at his wedding ring and if he's wearing
a ring you'll see the indentation from
it I mean you got to go a little bump up
bum bum bum right ma'am I don't know why
I blame it for you blaming you I have no
excuse for this [ __ ] guy I don't know
I mean what about George Clooney in that
that movie where he's flying around in
the planes and he showed up and that
woman at a family you know did he say
anything he didn't what was the call up
in the air right and he was banging that
woman and then he went to her house and
he found out that she was married and he
was like oh [ __ ] he just walked away
that's what guys do think we just we
just walk away women start pulling
hedges out of the front yard they start
putting rabbits in the [ __ ] stew and
[ __ ]
like is that why we die sooner than they
do because we just hold that in our
chest the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of family
and you just carry that around for the
rest of your life women get to get it
out we have to think if he has kids and
[ __ ] like maybe he's just going through
a [ __ ] phase that he's working it out
you're gonna blow up that family and
their dad's gonna leave and just just so
you know there's gonna be two kids
crying if this guy has kids does he have
kids
I know personally I would just take the
loss and I would move on I would just go
like listen I I checked you out I found
out you're married you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ]
and because I'm a cool chick I'm not
gonna call you [ __ ] wife
go [ __ ] yourself I mean you could do
that or you could just or you could just
say I don't I don't I don't know what to
tell you I can't throw another guy into
the bus like this that's what you would
do
there you go someone in the crowd so
that's what I would do keep losing
weight and move the [ __ ] on yeah but you
have to this is what you have to do yeah
you know what you got to look at that
guy like you got to look at that guy
like when Columbus was sailing across
the ocean he didn't see land first he
saw branches so he knew that something
good was coming right that he could
exploit and cut their arms off when they
didn't give enough gold okay
allegedly oh my god new evidence shows
that he was this what was you find none
did somebody scroll it into a [ __ ]
tree yeah just look at this guy okay
you're gonna have to either you're gonna
take some losses on your way to a
championship okay you don't blow up the
whole team and burn down the [ __ ]
arena that's what you want to do just
know this take it as a compliment you
lost so much weight you were worth
risking a house for I don't know I got
nothing all right you know what that is
the podcast this is the first ever live
podcast thank you guys so much for
coming out
hope you had a good time I hope you
enjoyed it I hope it was fun go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on ya on
Thursday thank you good night
[Applause]